موضوع رسالتي في الدكتوراه كان عن تقنيه
البلوكشن طبعا وقت ما كنت بدرسها كنت
منبهر بالبيت كوين والانفتيز وكل الاشياء
اللي ممكن تتحقق من خلال هذا التقنيه لكن
خلال بحث اكتشفت انه البلوك هين عباره عن
نقطه في بحر التقنيات اللي هتغير حياتنا
بشكل جيدري
طبعا اليوم هنتكلم عن هذه التقنيات هنتكلم
عن المتر فيرس هنتكلم عن الانترنت الاشياء
وعدد من مكونات السابع
خلينا ناخذها واحده واحده اول شيء هل
تتوقع هيجي يوم من الايام وتكون الاراضي
في المتر في عرس برنسفه او اكثر قيمه او
اغلى من الاراده في العالم الحقيقي
لكن السؤال الثاني هل تتوقع هذه الرسوم
اللي بنشوفها في الانترنت
وغيرها ممكن يكون لها نفس المكان في
المتاحف زي ال همم الرسمات اللي همم
بنشوفها بانجو موناليزا وغير ذلك
هل انتم اقرب لنموذج اللي على اليمين ولا
نموذج على اليسار هل تحسوا نفسكم اسعد
بعيد عن التكنولوجيا ولا تحس نفسكم ضروري
انكم تدبنوا كل التكنولوجيات الجديده وهل
تتوقع هيزي وقت راح يكون عندكم القدره على
او الخيار هيكون في يدكم فيما يتعلق بقبول
او رفض التقنيه
الفكره الاولى اللي باناقصها اليوم هي انه
التكنولوجيا اثار مجتمعيه عميقه خلينا
ناخذ على سبيل المثال الموسيقى في فتره من
الفترات كانت موسيقه ام كلثوم هي الستايل
الرائج والوحيد تقريبا في العالم العربي
يسمع من المحيط الى الخليج لكن جاءت لحظه
معينه واختفت موسيقى ام كلثوم تماما
تتعامل هذا الاختفاء مع اختراع جديد هو
الكاسات في الناس صار عندها اختيارات
كثيره صار في مغنيين كثير نزلوا اغانيهم
للساحه
هذا مثال يوريك كيف التكنولوجيا ممكن تغير
ابسط الاشياء في حياتنا حتى تستعائل
الموسيقى
اقل وهذا ياخذنا الى الفكره الثانيه هي ان
السابر في ذلك رحت تغير في حياتنا زي ما
التقنيات اللي كانت قبلها
اتسرقت في اا حياتنا طبعا خلينا نبدا
بتعريفها السابق في ذكرته هي كلمه من
جزئين حاولت اترجمها بالعربي ولكن تغلبت
الصراحه همم في جوجل طلعت لي الماديه
السيبرنيه بس ما في شيء اصلا في جوجل اسمه
الماده 70 على اي حال سابع فيزيكالتي
سايبر يعني عالم الشبكات عالم الانترنت
عالم ال- ال- الامور الرقميه بينما فيزلك
اللي هو عالم الاشياء الماديه اللي احنا
جزء منها طبعا في الزكاه التي هي ظاهره
تتميز بدوبان الفواصل ما بين هذين
العالمين
زي سمارت فون قدر يدمج بداخله الكاميرا
والكمبيوتر
والتلفزيون وغير ذلك من التقنيات ايضا في
السايبر في زكاه التي عدد كبير من
التقنيات راح تندمج فيما بينها وحتسمع
تجارب ما كانت موجوده في السابق طبعا هذا
التجارب تشمل طرق اخرى طرق جديده ما كنا
نفكر فيها في التعامل مع المحتوى الرقمي
على ال ال ال في الميديا مثل حاسه اللمس
حاسه اللمس راح تكون جزء اساسي في تعاملنا
مع المحتوى سواء التلفزيون سواء كان
المحتوى على الانترنت الحين بعد شويه نشرح
كيف كل واحده من هذه الاشياء هتتحقق من
خلال تقنيات معينه طبعا ايضا هتصير في طرق
جديده للاتفاعل مع الالات في السابق اول
ما بدانا نتعامل مع الكمبيوتر كان تعاملنا
يكون من خلال الماوس شوي شوي استنى نتعامل
من خلال همم التوت سكرين شوي شويه صار في
سيري صار في الاكثر صرنا من خلال الصوت
المرحله الجايه وهذا لسه خيال علمي
هنتعامل مع الكمبيوتر من خلال التفكير
يكفي انك تفكر في الشيء حتى الكمبيوتر
يوصلوا وهنتكلم عنه بالتفصيل في السلايدز
القادمه اخر تغير حنتكلم عنه من تغيرات
الصعبه في زكالتي هي ظهور البيئات الذكيه
متعدده الحواس
طيب خلينا نتكلم عن اربعه تقنيات ممكن
تساعد في تحقيق هذه الرؤيه التقنيه الاولى
هي انترنت الاشياء الفكره ببساطه الفكره
من الانترنت الاشياء هي انه جميع الاجهزه
في محاوله تكون مرتبطه فيما بعد في فيما
بينها وهذه الاجهزه تكون
رابط هذه الاجهزه الذكيه ينتج عنه بيئات
ذكيه ايش نقصد بالاجهزه الذكيه كيف ممكن
يكون الجهاز ذكي خلينا نفكر في الثلاجه
على سبيل المثال الثلاجه ممكن تكون ذكيه
بمعنى انها عندها واعي بالمحتويات
الموجوده بداخلها بالكميات عندها اواعي
بتواريخ الانتهاء وعندها اواعي
بالنتريس سنه القيمه الغذائيه للمحتويات
الثلاجه ممكن تقول لك اذا كان في شيء ناقص
في شيء يبغى لك تخفف منه وممكن تتخطى ذلك
لدرجه ابعد وتكون بالتواصل مع السوبر
ماركت وتعمل الطلب بشكل مباشر
فخلينا نروح لتقنيه رقم 2 اللي هتنقلنا
لهذا العالم عالم
التقنيه رقم اثنين هي الميورال
الانترفيسيس طبعا هذه الفكره بدات لمساعده
عدد من الاشخاص يعني يعانون من مشكله
صعوبه التواصل مع العالم الخارجي في انواع
من انواع معينه من الشلل تصاعد على
الانسان مثلا استخدام الكمبيوتر الى ذلك
تكون هذه الطريقه تسهل عن انسان بانه يلبس
شيء فراسه ويتكلم يعني يكتب بيعمل تشات
مثلا او يتواصل مع الكمبيوتر طبعا هذه
شكلها كانها خيال علمي لكن يوجد ابحاث
اوراق بحثيه كثير عن هذا الموضوع ويوجد
ايضا تجارب جامعيه وصلت في مرحله في مراحل
لا باس بها من التقدم طبعا هي ما هي
موجوده بشكل تجاري لكن هذا الشيء واقع
قيد التطوير فتخيلوا لو كان انترنت اشياء
ربط كل الاجهزه في المنزل ومن خلال
الانترفيس بامكانك تتحكم بكل حاجه الاجهزه
في المنزل هل هذا الشيخ خلينا اكثر كفاء
بحيث انه يكون عندنا الوقت ان نقوم ونعمل
خشن نبغاه والانسير اكثر كسلا لانه خلاص
تعبنا نبقى نطفي النور مجرد التفكير في
النور المقفل التلفزيون ينفتح كيف هيكون
السيناري واحد 20 ممكن يعني نفكر فيه
التقنيه الثالثه اللي هتنقلنا لهذا العالم
اللي نقدر نتفاعل فيه مع المحتوى بشكل
جديد هي الاوجمنت اللي عليك
هي القدره اننا نشوف العالم ال- ال- مع
البيئه الواقعيه اللي احنا فيها فبذلك
مثلا اشهر مثال لهذا الشيء لا اريد موجود
لعبه بوكيمون جو طبعا لعبه فواكه من جوجل
بامك تشوف البوكيمون من خلال همم شاشه
الكمبيوتر وتصوره وتتفاعل مع من خلال
الجوال طبعا هذا الشيء موجود في الهندسه
او ممكن يكون بشكل نظاره طبعا هذا الشيء
يعني مو بعيد لانه
هنتكلم عن التقنيه الاخيره شايفين الزر
الموجود في منتصف الايفون هذا الزر في
الحقيقه هو ليس غير هو عباره عن
احساس بالضغط لو شفته انه البطاريه فضيت
تضغط
يعني احساس بالضغط اسمه حاجتك فيد باك
فالهابتك في باك همم
تقنيه هذه حبتك في الباك تعطيني حاسه
اللمس في التفاعل مع المحتوى الرقمي بدل
ما يكون زر بحادث طبعا اكثر الاشكال
بدائيه للهابتك فيد ماكو زر الايفون لكن
ممكن يكون عباره عن بدله لمن بنتفرج موفي
ممكن نحس باحساس المطر لو احد بيلعب
ملاكمه ممكن يحس بالكدمات في اللعبه اذا
احد همم بيتفرج فيلم رعب في زومبي في شركس
تخيلوا كيف هتكون همم التجربه في التعامل
مع هذه همم مع المحتوى الرقمي طبعا هذه
كانت اربعه تقنيات من تقنيات عديده راح
تغير طريقه تعاملنا مع الميدي هتغير
مجتمعنا ايضا فخلينا نفكر في بعض العواقب
قبل ما اتكلم في في العواقب في عقبه ما
اضفتها الاسلام بس حبيتك برده تفكر فيها
هي البرايسيه تخيلوا كمل معلومات للفيسبوك
بجميعها الان وغيرهم جميعا
كيف هيكون مستوى الخصوصيه والغياب
الخصوصيه بس خلينا ناخذ واحده واحده خلينا
نتكلم عن النفسيه فيما يتعلق في ظاهره
اكتشف طبعا مشهوره في اليابان لك هي
موجوده في كل مكان هي اله كيكو موري هي
عباره عن اشخاص عندهم مشكله انهم ما
يقدروا يخرجوا من البيت لشهور عديده لانهم
قاعدين على الكمبيوتر طول الوقت فطبعا هل
هذه التقنيه راح هذا النوع من التطور
التقني حيخليهم اكثر عزله وقاعدين في
البيت ولا ممكن تساعده هؤلاء الاشخاص لما
يخرجوا فتخيلوا مثلا لو سيري كان عندها
همم سيري او اليكسا كان عندها جسد وشخصيه
احنا ممكن نختارها فهل ممكن تلعب دور
المعالج النفسي او دور صديقي يساعد هذا
الانسان على الخروج ممكن يصير الناس تكتفي
بالشخصيات ال- ال-
وتبطل تتعامل مع الناس الحقيقيين
خلينا نروح على التعليم اتخيلوا الاطفال
ممكن يجروا داخل البراكين ويتفرجوا عليها
من الداخل بدل ما يقراوا عنها في الكتاب
تخيلوا لو كان طلاب الطب بدل ما يجربه اول
عمليه لهم على انسان حقيقي ممكن تكون
شخصيه افتراضيه مع الفرش والتولز بحيث
الهاف دكتورز بحيث تقدروا يحسوا بالضغطه
المقص يقدر يحسبه كل هذه الامور هل هيصير
هنوصل لدرجه فيها اعتماد شديد على
التقنيات الحديثه بحيث يصير اكثر في
الفيلسوف اليوناني القديم
افلاطون سال سؤال قال كان بيحاول يقنع
الناس انه الكتاب بيخلي الناس اكثر همم
اقل القدره على التذكر لانه صارت الناس
تعتمد على الكتاب بدل ما تعتمد على
الاشياء الثانيه طبعا نفس السؤال عدد جوجل
كانت جوجل بيخليني كل الالات اللي حوالين
اثاره الذكيه هل احنا حنصير همم اقل ذكاء
مثلا فيعني خلينا ننتقل بعدها
هل سيصبح هناك نوع جديد من الفقر بحيث
يكون في مجتمعات وافراد غير قادرين عن
المشاركه في التعليم والعمل بسبب عدم
قدرتهم على الحصول على هذا الاجهزه التي
قد تكون مكلفه
في مبدا جميل جدا ويمكن يكون اجمل شيء في
السابع في زكالته هو الديجيتال سيتي
الندره الرقميه طبعا الذهب ليش سعره غالي
لانه ما ينفع الانسان يطبع منه زي بعض
العملات الورقيه او كل العملات الورقيه
فهذا المبدا الديجت الاسكارستي قام عليه
اقتصاد البنت كله عمله البيتكوين قامت على
هذا المبدا الان فتيس كلها قائمه على هذا
المبدا اللي هيغير الاقتصاد وحيغير كل شيء
بشكل كبير اخر فكره ابى اتكلم عنها هي
السايبركس طبعا السايبركس همم هم هي هو
تصور بدا في ساينس فكشن انه يكون الانسان
نصه انسان نصفه ولكن ال- ال- الفكره لها
عدد كبير من التخيلات ممكن يكون الانسان
المعتمد بشكل كبير في حياته على التقنيه
يعتبر سايبك بمعنى انه ما يقدر يستغني
عنها بمعنى من المعاني ان احنا كلنا
نعتبرته هتخلينا كلنا تدفعنا اكثر في
اتجاهها السابقه ولا همم
شيء كويس او شيء مو كويس انا شخصيا عجبتني
يعني الموضوع بس طبعا كل واحد هي الاسئله
لازم نفكر فيها وكيف ممكن نتعامل معها كيف
لو كنا ارتيس وتس وايش نوع الفنان
يعني في قرارات كثيره ممكن تاثر حتى على
مسيرتنا المهني اخيرا ابى احط كل الكاملته
في كونتكس معين العالم كان اقتصاده مبني
على الزراعه انتقلنا من فتره الزراعه الى
فتره التصنيع فتره التصنيع او الثوره
الصناعيه ممكن نجسمها لاربع مراحل المرحله
الاولى هي فتره المرحله الثانيه هي فتره
الانتاج الكميمي اكشن المرحله الثالثه هي
الرقم انا او الديزل واخيرا احنا اليوم في
فتره السابر في ذكرى ويوجد ابحاث كثيره
بدات تنشر عن الفتره ما بعد السابقه لكن
وقفت هنا لانه هسا اقرب
وفي اشياء جميله جدا قد يكون رهيب وقد
يكون مخيف ليست فور يو ثان
[تصفيق]